well joining me now are legendary KISS
frontman Gene Simmons who's just
announced dates for one final World Tour
legendary former talk show host uh ex
Mayor of Cincinnati and current TV icon
because that never gets taken away Jerry
Springer well welcome to both of you uh
like I say greatest panel ever assembled
Gene Simmons
um you're 73 I believe and you've
decided to end things with kiss in terms
of touring is that an age-related
decision by the band
well yes it is you know part and parcel
of being around for 50 years longer than
you've been alive young man we've been
touring we've been touring since the
last century literally speaking and at a
certain point pride self-respect and
everything says get off the stage so at
73 years of age right now still have
hair much more on my back unfortunately
the physicality just gets in the way I
mean we're not Blues performers we don't
stand still and just strum acoustic
guitar I wear Dragon boots that have the
weight of a bowling ball about 40 pounds
in all they've got to spit fire flying
through the air at a certain at a
certain point self-respect says be
grateful thankful and get off the stage
and do you think Gene should the same
logic apply to presidents I mean if
Biden he's already 80 he'd be 86 if he
was to run again and win and he's
already showing signs what many people
think of you know first onset a set of
dementia should he be able to run as
president of this age
no I don't think so and that doesn't
mean that I agree or don't agree with
the politics politics aside there should
be a test to find out if somebody has
their their wits about them number one
you're talking about the most powerful
person on Earth and also to find out
whether or not somebody is absolutely
nuts
there should be a qualification a
medical qualification and psychological
qualification that somebody in charge
isn't just going to go nuts and go like
that or fall down the stairs okay try to
go up on Air Force One okay let me
bringing uh Jerry on this because Nikki
Haley is one of the other Republican uh
candidates she actually did say
something very similar here's what she
said
in the America I see the permanent
politician will finally retire
[Applause]
we'll have term limits for congress
and mandatory mental competency tests
for politicians over 75 years old
[Applause]
Now Jerry you were about 15 when you
were married Cincinnati from memory it
was a very long time ago but you're a
young man don't these jobs require a
certain degree of mental agility uh
certainly watching a country like
America which you would think that every
year after 80 you're probably losing
your powers right
well first of all if we had a mental
acuity test uh for people who are going
to be president we never would have had
Trump uh there are a whole bunch of
other people that aren't older you know
uh
so that that issue I I put aside Biden
is an exceptional case now the we can
discuss whether he's too old to be
president but the fact of the matter is
the only person that actually knows that
for a fact
is the person or persons who examined
him everyone else just has an opinion
he's being tested whether or not he has
those facilities now the question is
when I look at the evidence this man in
two and a half years has accomplished
more than any American president since
Franklin Roosevelt with a possible
exception of Lyndon Johnson on domestic
policies now a lot of people don't like
what he's done but when you take a look
at the things that he's accomplished
this is not a man with dementia lowering
Healthcare inflation reduction these
wonderful things questioning that I
understand as a Democrat you think
they're all wonderful a lot of
Republicans think he's done a series of
terrible things but but there's no doubt
there's no doubt the midterm election
results for example were in some way a
validation of Biden's presidency so far
it was a lot better than people thought
might happen my question when you see
him do that clip this week where he
talks about him taking off the top of
his head to see if he has a brain a
mumbling
trying to make a silly
no he started a joke and halfway through
it realized this thing is falling flat
trust me I've been there so that's yeah
Jerry you're how old are you now if you
don't mind me asking I'm 79 right and
you've never stopped working I know that
your leather stop working right
well I might but it
I think I still have my mental acuity I
think I may stop because there are the
things I want to do I want to spend more
time with Richard my grandson and follow
him in baseball and basketball and do
things like that so it's more that
decision more than a medical decision
here's what I believe is happening
overwhelmingly every poll shows
that the vast majority of people who
think Biden is too old or conservative
and Republican now there are Democrats
who think he's too old but when you ask
them why they think he's too old is they
worry that if he's at the top of the
ballot other people will think he's too
old and the ballot and and their whole
ticket will go down the drain that's a
political worry but if you're asking the
question is he competent to be president
of the United States there is absolutely
no evidence on his record so far
I can see Gene wanting to get back in
here Gene
sorry look let's call it let's call it
for what it is
um I'm on both sides of the fence about
all sorts of political issues so you
can't call me a rabid Democrat or
conservative or liberal or any of that
you know I'm everybody's worst enemy
because I simply vote on the issues but
let's call it the way it is the masses I
don't believe for a second vote on
political platform they wouldn't be able
to explain to you anything it is
invariably and intrinsically another big
words like gymnasium the cult of
personality when people saw when people
saw Nixon with his five o'clock shadow
before any of you were born it was a TV
and sweating debate between Kennedy and
Nixon and he had the five o'clock shadow
nobody remembers what they stood for or
who was a Democrat they just didn't like
that guy who looked like uh you know
Uncle Joe who's drinking a little too
much he just didn't look so so when
people watch Mr Trump who we both know
they have their perception and when
people watch Mr Biden and we've all seen
him on TV and stuff unfortunately
sometimes turning around to shake hands
with people who aren't there or mumbling
words that doesn't mean I agree or don't
agree with the politics people will
judge this following political
uh battle based on personality I have
not met regular people who've been able
to explain to me what the different
political platforms are so I believe Mr
Button is in deep trouble I just want to
say one one last thing very quickly if I
was on the other side Mr Trump's side
and I may not be actually I have lots of
problems with him somebody is going to
put together a greatest hits of Mr Biden
falling off bicycles falling on the
stairs and not even talk about politics
not even talk about politics and that
person can you imagine but can you
imagine yeah Jerry let me just say to
you I think I think the bigger the
bigger problem Jerry for Democrats I
think is not really Trump who remains
the bogeyman that may get out the
Democrat vote Ash has it happened last
time so that might be the worst scenario
for the Republicans if Trump does win
the nomination but if it's someone like
Governor Ron DeSantis who's in his 40s
full of energy full of dynamism you know
on a tough campaign Trail I would not
want to be a Democrat trying to have
Biden as my guy against a bloke half his
age with that kind of energy just purely
let me see this Gene just mentioned okay
let me just say this I absolutely agree
with you that there would be a political
burden with Biden at the top of the
ticket I totally recognize that
but I'm on the show because the question
was is Biden too old to be president
yeah on that issue he is not too old
based on his performance
is there a political price to pay
absolutely so Gene I have no argument
with what you just said I agree with you
totally but the issue is is he too old
objectively in his case I'm not saying
another 84 year old or 82 year old I'm
saying him I'm saying objective well I
know people
other than you two who bursts with
radiant vitality and Youthful dynamism I
know people like Dame Joan Collins who's
nearly 90 and is like a 50 year old you
know Warren Buffett people like this are
in the 90s still as sharp as a whip
there are also people I know who are in
their late 80s 90s who are incredibly on
it my issue with Biden is when you see
all these gaffes and all these stumbles
and everything else he looks to me like
he's already feeling his age at 80 and
that would be a concern for me but
anyway guys I've got to leave it there
Jerry brilliant to see you again we work
together on America's Got Talent and
Gene great to see you we were together
on Celebrity Apprentice and thank God
you pulled out after a few episodes
because that allowed me to win because I
think if you'd stayed in I'd have been
dead man so thank you Gene Simmons for
your selfless Act
great to see you guys take care